welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and werewolf by
night just introduced us to a new
powerful artifact in the MCU the
Bloodstone after watching this Marvel
horror special we know about the
bloodstone's primary uses and Abridged
history but there's a lot more lore
behind this gem than you might realize
so today I'm breaking down everything we
know about the Bloodstone where it came
from and what it might be used for in
the future of the MCU it's not a secret
that phase 4 of the MCU is a lot of
setup for future phases after the big
payoff of infinity war and end game most
of the movies and TV series in their
wake have been devices for Paris for
future team-ups new Heroes and a whole
lot of super chaos y'all know I'm an
especially huge fan of all the recent
MCU TV shows and I think that I might
even enjoy some of them more than
certain films in the catalog but nearly
all of these properties have opened a
lot more doors than they've closed
werewolf by night is no exception in
addition to the eternals introduction of
Blade the alleged vampire saracen from
She-Hulk Egyptian deities from Moon
Knight and zombie strange we now have
werewolves and man thing added to the
roster we're approaching a supernatural
Renaissance in the MCU where traditional
monsters might occasionally take the
place of traditional super villains and
that's where the Bloodstone comes in we
now have a specific tool floating around
reserved for fighting creatures of the
night in the same way that an infinity
stone made its user all the more
powerful in each of their respective
areas of augmented intensity the
Bloodstone makes its users stronger
against the supernatural as we learned
in werewolf By Night the Bloodstone has
the power to Grant its user enhanced
strength endurance and Longevity not
only can It keep its owner Immortal it
also weakens the strength of monsters
allowing them to be defeated more easily
in the comics it also rescues Ulysses a
few times at one point he begins to
drown and the stone itself carries him
to the surface it also can proved
regeneration and even ESP although
Ulysses Bloodstone was the only
telepathic user in its history most
importantly the Bloodstone allows you to
use a red blast of energy against your
enemies not unlike the reality Stone but
let's back up and start at the beginning
like the beginning beginning predating
the universe itself a race of Elder Gods
existed in an alien Universe devolving
into destruction and disorder in order
to conquer other realities the blood gem
was created like the Infinity Stones the
Bloodstone and the comics used to go by
the term gem instead of stone the blood
gem became a conduit for the Hellfire
Helix aka the point in reality where all
energy and Magic passes through somehow
these condensed energies formed a
sentience known as the exomind although
the elders entrusted the EXO mind to
find five guardians to help them perform
the world melding rituals the exomine
had its servants Alexia steal the blood
gem from the gods chaos doing as chaos
does this action was simply on a whim of
the exomind you'll Excel yielded the gem
into time and space and it was seemingly
lost for quite some time spoiler alert
this is not the color hair that I was
born with but I love it my hair is as
much of a part of who I am as my face or
my spleen arguably more than my spleen
my hair makes me happy so that's why I
want to make my hair happy and that's
why I'm stoked about geology co-wash and
I know you're all thinking geology isn't
that the 13 times award-winning skin
care company with over 5 000 5 Star
reviews uh yes they are but now they do
hair too and I'm super excited about it
geology has a new custom control hair
care line with brand new co-wash co-wash
is the anti-shampoo shampoo strips your
hair of the essential oils the scalp
produces and can leave your hair and
scalp too dry typical shampoos use harsh
chemicals to clean your hair but co-wash
uses friction and scrubbing motion to
remove dirt and grime from your scalp
keeping your hair clean and healthy
without damaging it in the process good
hair comes from having a healthy scalp
co-wash focus is on cleaning and
nourishing the scalp removing buildup
and cleansing the hair without big
lather harsh ingredients or stripping
the hair of its natural oils co-wash
puts you a hundred percent in control of
your clean based on how much product you
use how long you use it and how often
you apply it think of co-wash as skin
care for your scalp and hair because
ultimately Hair Care is skin care
geology hair products are great for all
hair types and are color safe and you
can either get a cooling co-wash with
tea tree and yellow or a smoothing
co-wash with avocado and coconut I'm a
tea tree and aloe kind of person why
because you can never be too cool baby
to celebrate the launch of their new
product they're hooking you up with this
unbelievable special offer click the
link below to get 70 off a skincare
trial but not only that use the second
link to take an additional 15 off the
new co-wash which is already 15 off for
the pre-order you're not going to want
to miss this offer in the TV series we
see a drawing in the opening credits of
five nights guarding the Bloodstone
surrounded by the phases of the moon
minus the full moon I believe that the
five guardians from the comics inspired
the figures we see in this diagram the
gem ended up landing on krillar where
scientists discovered that the remnants
had fallen as a result of the Big Bang
they put the pieces together along with
other assorted primordial power shards
brought to the cree by the skrulls gr
and the badoon to form the life Stone
tree the life Stone tree would give
eight protectors the strength to guard
the universe for hundreds of years this
Coalition of Guardians was known as the
Guardians of the Galaxy no relation to
quill and his team when the members of
the Guardians of the Galaxy started to
die off space pirates stepped in to
steal the life Stone tree for themselves
this event caused an explosion that cast
the pieces of the life stones into the
far reaches of space due to a spatial
anomaly a great number of the shards
ended up on Earth the blood gem itself
was one of these shards and landed on
the European continent during the
hiborian Age around 8250 BC the exomind
relinked its connection to the stone and
began searching for a host to wield his
prized possession upon discovering
Ulysses who eventually went on to become
the Monster Hunter Ulysses Bloodstone
that we met in werewolf By Night the
exomind had its servant Elixir lead him
to a cave where the gem was kept at the
altar the EXO mind gave Ulysses the
power of the blood gem greatly expanding
his mind the hunter eagerly went back to
his tribe intending to share with them
the blood gems power unfortunately the
blood gems sowed chaos into the people
of his village and they all died
horrifically when faced with the stone
Ulysses attempted to shatter the jam but
one of the pieces of the gem was
embedded deep inside his chest sort of
like a prehistoric Twist on the Arc
Reactor after accident mentally
murdering everyone he knew and loved
Ulysses Bloodstone vowed to use his
powers to save Humanity from monsters
aliens and other reality threatening
beings his prime target would be Elixir
who from his perception was the cause of
his tribe's death to keep Ulysses as its
host for thousands of years the exomind
would have Legions of monsters drawn to
him preventing him from achieving his
true core Ulysses ended up becoming the
most fearsome wealthy hunter in the
world due to the Stone's unique powers
not knowing that he housed the life form
he wished to kill after tiring of seeing
the world through Ulysses eye the
exomind organized a group of followers
known as The Conspiracy to kill him
promising them the same eternal life as
Ulysses the conspiracy worked with the
EXO mind to collect other fragments of
the blood gem the conspiracy then
extracted Ulysses gem for themselves
once fully collected the EXO mind stole
their life force to create a physical
body for itself but Bloodstone was able
to psychically penetrate the EXO mind
and seemingly destroy it killing himself
in the process the Bloodstone would be
inherited by Ulysses estranged daughter
Elsa Bloodstone housed in a choker that
could empower or her by biting into her
neck Elsa took up the family line of
work reckon Monster's skulls and turned
Dracula into Ash in the comics she and
her mom returned to her estranged
deceased father's home and Elsa is given
the necklace by a Frankenstein named
Adam obviously this is extremely
different from what happens in werewolf
finite in the MCU Elsa along with five
of the best monster hunters in the world
gather at her to cease father's estate
to compete for the Bloodstone also just
an opinion but the cute little choker
necklace from the comics is way more
convenient than lugging that thing
around on an iron chain after the comic
Multiverse collapsed into battle World a
scenario the MCU seems to be heading
towards with all these incursion hints
Elsa faced a multiversal counterpart of
her father who was collecting Bloodstone
fragments Luke Skywalker and cut off her
hands but she was able to use the
collective power of the Bloodstone
fragments to reform her hand with the
Bloodstone embedded into it so what does
this all mean for the MCU I think that
my vampire Theory from last week might
actually align with this one ESC the
Elder gods of chaos created the
Bloodstone to break in into our
Dimension who's one of those big shot
Elder Gods we know of cathon yup the
beings dark hold on the Multiverse was
just severed by the Scarlet Witch that's
gonna make him pissed and he could
reasonably be adapted as the force
behind the EXO mind if he can assemble
enough Bloodstone shards by influencing
monsters he might be able to use the
Stone's initial purpose to find another
way into our universe and have his
revenge or if my vampire theory is even
sort of correct and monstrous followers
of cathon are trying to re-establish
their connection to him they could be
like the conspiracy a group of monsters
unwittingly seeking Power by uniting the
Stones only to unleash true chaos to
achieve their goals they'll have to down
out the Bloodstone but that might prove
challenging if she gets a similar
power-up in a phase six battle World Arc
uh Secret Wars if true it sounds like
athon might be our phase seven or eight
big bad follow me on Instagram and
Twitter whitneypuppy follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you